the Department of Justice inspector
general releases its long-awaited report
on the FBI's handling of the Hillary
investigation we will break the entire
thing down for you and we'll check the
mailbag i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
oh man yesterday was a boring news day
until it was not my goodness a bunch of
news just broke in the middle of the
afternoon and has continued until the up
through today and we will go through all
of it in just one second first I want to
make sure that you know about the
conversations we're having an episode of
the conversation next week on Tuesday
June 19 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m.
Pacific all of your questions will be
answered by yours truly Ben Shapiro with
our host Alicia Krauss our live Q&A will
be available on YouTube and Facebook for
everybody to watch but only subscribers
can actually ask me questions over at
Daily wire comm check out the pin
comments on this video for more
information about how to do that so
again subscribe and you can ask me those
live questions Tuesday June 19 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific I mean listen
I'm ruining my afternoon for you guys so
join the conversation and subscribe make
sure you are there also before we begin
I want to talk to you about life
insurance so sorry to break it to you if
you didn't know about it you go and die
and when you do you want to make sure
that you actually have life insurance so
that your family is not left
impoverished I mean the reality is that
without your income and without then
having to pay for all your funeral
expenses like life insurance is good for
a lot of things if you're a responsible
person you have life insurance for your
parents for your siblings for your
whoever it is that is your immediate
family your life insurance is necessary
that's why you need policy genius comso
policy genius is the easy way to compare
life insurance online in just five
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers to find the best policy for
you and when you compare quotes you save
money it is indeed that simple in fact
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance they have
placed over twenty billion dollars in
coverage and it's not just life
insurance they also do disability
insurance renter's insurance health
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it go check it out right now
policy genius.com it's never been easier
to get life insurance and if you don't
want to think about life insurance well
good news policy genius takes care of it
for you in the blink of an eye so go
check it out policy genius calm it's the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance once again policy genius com
go take care of it and be a responsible
human being ok
speaking of irresponsible human beings
my goodness so yesterday the Department
of Justice and the inspector general
release a report on the FBI's handling
of the Hillary Clinton email
investigation oh my god ok so as you
know I've been very skeptical about a
lot of the conspiracy theories
surrounding the last election cycle
about the conspiracy theory that the f
I was targeting President Trump and his
campaign during the campaign I've been
very skeptical of that I've explained
why my skepticism I was saying the
evidence was not there to support it and
I was very suspicious that the that all
the rumors about the FBI attacking
president from this was just being
overblown for partisan reasons well
color me a lot more suspicious today
that those rumors are true
coloring me a lot more suspicious today
that the that the plan to take down
president Trump's campaign may not in
fact just because you're paranoid
doesn't mean they're not out to get you
I mean that's basically what I'm got
garnering from the Department of Justice
inspector general report because the key
finding from this inspector general
report is there were indeed agents at
the FBI who are politically motivated to
stop President Trump from being
president and they were deeply involved
in both a Hillary investigation and the
Russia investigation now this particular
Inspector General report was not about
the Russia investigation so President
Trump said today for example that the
report proved there was no collusion it
didn't okay that that is not part of the
report we'll find out whether there was
collusion or not so far no evidence of
collusion and the whole thing looks like
it's going to come up empty but that
could be wrong right we'll go where the
evidence takes us but what this report
did cover was the FBI's handling of the
Hillary investigation and the key agent
in the Hillary investigation was an
impede struck right you've heard of him
because we've talked about him before
Peter struck of course is the guy who
was texting with his live-in lover he's
texting with Lisa Paige his paramour
another FBI agent they're both married
so they're both just lovely human beings
and they were texting with each other
throughout the campaign and Peter struck
was very anti Trump there are a lot of
these texts that came out but the
biggest story that came out from the
inspector general's report is that Peter
struck was basically texting with his
lover that he was going to use his power
at the FBI in order to stop President
Trump it's very difficult to read his
text any other way so let's go through
the inspector general's report it is 528
pages that report I spent a lot of
yesterday reading it I didn't want to
give full comments on it on yesterday's
show because it broke you know while the
show was was happening in a little bit
afterward and I really wanted to give
the whole thing perusal before I before
I jump to conclusions about the report I
have now read the report and it's not
good for James Comey the former head of
the FBI it is certainly not good for the
FBI as a whole it's terrible for Peter
struck and it's bad for Hillary Clinton
as well it is just not good all the way
around so there are 12 key findings of
this and we're going to go through all
of them when we finish today's show
you're going to know everything
you needed to know about the Inspector
General report and you too I think will
be a lot more suspicious that the FBI
was attempting to do the bidding of the
Obama administration the unspoken
bidding of the Obama administration and
stopped President Trump from being
president and also to to sort of kowtow
to Hillary Clinton the great irony by
the way is that the FBI that wanted
Hillary Clinton to be President these
these key players in the FBI then wanted
Hillary Clinton to be President in their
attempt to make sure that Hillary
Clinton was a quote-unquote legitimate
president they probably prevented her
from becoming president it's really
ironic and in kind of hilarious so let's
jump right in first of all FBI agents
Lisa Paige and Peter struck texted
openly about stopping Trump hey not just
we don't like Trump not just we think
Trump's a schmuck actually about
stopping Trump so struck texted page
that he would stop it it being Trump's
election so the actual texts are pretty
incredible the actual texts suggest let
me read it to you page text you struck
quote Trump's not ever going to become
president right right this this is
August 2016 and struck rights back no no
he won't we'll stop it who is we
who is we okay so people on the Left are
hanging their hat on maybe we as all the
Democrats how the Democrats are gonna
rise up and stop it yeah as plausible
that's plausible when my wife says you
know don't tell me no one's gonna pick
up the kids and I say don't worry I'll
stop it I don't mean like I collectively
I don't mean like the nanny I mean like
I will take care of it right we'll stop
it sounds like we in our official
capacity by the way this is what the
Inspector General report found right the
IG report found that the text quote
potentially indicated or created the
appearance that investigative decisions
were impacted by bias or improper
considerations the report added quote it
is not only indicative of a bias state
of mind but even more seriously implies
a willingness to take official action to
impact the presidential candidates
electoral prospects this is antithetical
to the core values of the FBI and the
Department of Justice now you remember
yesterday when we talked about this this
I'd report the main headline coming out
from the mainstream media which we
talked about was that there was no
political bias in the FBI targeting
President Trump or directed exonerating
Hillary Clinton but the reality is
that's not what the report says what the
report basically says is that they can't
find evidence of political bias in the
decision-making itself that the
decisions may have been made the same
way if there were no political bias but
the report also says that strux texts
do demonstrate a fair amount of
political bias at the FBI and as we'll
see that political bias played into a
wide variety of decisions that happened
in the course of the election campaign
the report found that Hillary that the
Hillary investigation was not adversely
impacted by struck or pages decision
making but this report did not cover the
Russia investigation right it did not
cover whether struck and people who
thought like him were involved in the
Russia investigation and to what extent
they decided to pervert the Russia
investigation or accelerate the Russia
investigation because they did not like
president Trump personally okay the
second point from the IG report James
Comey concluded that he would let
Hillary Clinton off in spring 2016
so you recall it was not until July that
James Comey made his big announcement
where he said Hillary Clinton is guilty
but we're not gonna prosecute her you
remember he made that big announcement
it was a big deal because James Comey is
is an idiot okay well Comey did not
announce that decision until July 2016
according to the report he had already
made the decision in spring of 2016
months earlier before Hillary Clinton
was even interviewed that Hillary was
off the hook
he also determined that he should make
an independent announcement in order to
protect quote a sense of justice more
broadly in the country that things are
fair not fixed and they're done
independently so he was afraid the DOJ
would look bad if they made the
announcement exonerating Hillary Clinton
and he thought well what if I just step
up and I take the hit and then the FBI
looks independent from the DOJ the DOJ
doesn't look like it was in control
everybody's happy except that wasn't his
role also worth noting this is an
amazing thing okay so they show what the
original Comey statement looked like and
how it was changed before the final
draft there were major changes made
between commis original draft of the
statement exonerating Hillary Clinton
and commis final draft of the statement
exonerating Hillary Clinton what were
some of those changes well one of the
changes was that the original statement
mentioned that President Obama himself
had been in an email exchange with
Hillary Clinton on her private server
his name was removed and that entire
piece of information was removed
why of course to protect President Obama
so the idea that Comey was not
applicable that political actor that of
course is ridiculous and speaking of
that statement
the original draft statement also said
that Hillary had been grossly negligent
which sounds a lot like law breaking
instead that was changed to extremely
careless the statement was changed from
reasonably likely that Hillary had been
hacked by hostile actors to possible and
finally again the original statement
mentioned that President Obama had been
an email exchange with Hillary and his
name was removed okay fourth
here Comey is an absolute glory hound so
when President Trump said that James
Comey was a glory hound that he was a
publicity hound that was exactly right
that was exactly right James Comey loves
him some James Comey and that is
absolutely clear from this IG report so
Comey
had already concluded before the tarmac
meeting between Loretta Lynch and Bill
Clinton that he was likely to make his
own statement on Hillary Clinton he
quote acknowledged that he made a
conscious decision not to tell
department leadership about his plans to
make a separate statement because he was
concerned they would instruct him not to
do in other words he wanted to make a
public statement he was afraid the DOJ
would say no so he just decided not to
ask mommy and daddy and just go do it
himself in violation of all protocol
again the idea here was to protect the
integrity of the FBI right this is
really what James Comey was super
worried about the IDS language here is
pretty damning they say we determined
that commis decision to make this
statement was the result of his belief
that only he had the ability to credibly
and authoritative Lee convey the
rationale for the decision to not seek
charges against Clinton and that he
needed to hold the press conference to
protect the FBI and the department from
the extraordinary harm he believed would
have resulted had he failed to do so
while we found no evidence that commis
statement was the result of bias or an
effort to influence the election we did
not find his justifications for issuing
the statement to be reasonable or
persuasive so it's plausible the Comey
was not attempting to impact the
election when he made that statement or
how he made the statement and that he
was attempting to protect the FBI but
they did water down the law okay the
reality is and this is the fifth point
here they did water down the law Kay the
IG in the inspector general's report
says that based on precedent Hillary
would have had to have demonstrated a
state of mind that was quote so gross as
to almost suggest deliberate intention
number one that is not part of the law
okay there's not part of the law second
of all this was not Hillary Clinton
using a private email account for
business right this was not that this
was Hillary Clinton specifically setting
up a private server at her own home okay
that is a lot more technologically
advanced than me just having a gmail
account she set up a private server at
her own home to store data the only
reason you do that is because you want
to make sure that you can destroy the
data afterward that is legitimately the
only reason that you would do that the
only reason you would do that is that it
is not on the government servers that is
the only reason there is no other reason
that is deliberate intention hey it's
not that you have to have deliberate
intention to give the material to a
foreign source you have to have
deliberate intention to not
free classified material property and
she obviously had that intention but
they changed the law to exonerate her
okay six point this one is just amazing
this is amazing
so the IG report found that the Anthony
Weiner case agent had spotted Hillary's
emails on September 26 2016 and he
informed the New York field office on
September 28th so in other words by late
September the FBI already knew that new
Hillary emails were on Anthony Weiner's
computer so why did it take until
October 28th for them to actually
investigate that information this one is
a stunner
and I'm gonna tell you about that in
just a second first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at software advice
so here's the reality your computer your
company right now probably is not doing
its best work with regard to the
software you have you probably do not
have them best software because you
haven't thought about updating it in a
really long time and it seems like it's
gonna be a pain in the butt and you
don't know anything about software you
have no idea what kind of software your
company actually needs well this is why
you need to go to software advice.com
okay their team of advisers can point
you in the right direction so you can
start working more effectively right
away you have to be up on the latest
technology software advice.com /ban lets
you do that he answer a few short
questions about your business you'll be
connected with an advisor to discuss the
best software options for your needs and
talking to an advisor takes just 10
minutes or less it doesn't matter
whether you're a medical professional or
a construction manager or you work at
the daily wire software advice will save
you time and help you make a more
informed decision if you're an
entrepreneur if you're working solo
again you can't afford to be using
outdated technology it wastes time and
waste effort instead go get the best
software advice with software advice
calm these experts are ready to be your
on-call go-to team to help you figure
out business software in minutes for
free check them out go to software at
vice.com slash bend to get started that
software advice.com
slash been to get started to connect
with an advisor for free today
software advice comm slash Bend then you
can connect for free and check it out
and use the / buttons let them know we
set you again software advice.com
already so why exactly was it that
between September 26th and October 28th
the FBI did nothing about the fact that
Hillary Clinton's emails or on Anthony
Weiner's computer deputy FBI director
Andrew McCabe knew about it the same day
that they found out about it in
September he then mentioned it directly
to James Comey and nobody mentioned it
again for nearly a full month just prior
to the election the report says quote we
found that by no later than September
29th FBI executives
the FBI minier team had learned
virtually every fact that was cited by
the FBI in late October as justification
for obtaining the search warrant for the
Weiner laptop Comey hilariously said he
didn't realize that Anthony Weiner was
married to Huma Abedin so the head of
the FBI did not know about one of the
most famous and and under assault
marriages in the history of the United
States Anthony Weiner and Huma Abedin
he's the most ignorant person in the
world and he runs the damn FBI okay and
then it gets even better so why is it
that they waited a month it turns out
they waited a month because they had it
turns out varying priorities they
weren't focused on Hillary Clinton's
emails to that point why weren't they
focused on Hillary Clinton's emails at
that point because there were other
things they were focused on well what
were some of those other things
according to the IG report the FBI was
focused on a Comey speech that would
fight back against public perception of
his July 5th announcement and they were
focused on the Russia investigation the
IG report says quote moreover given the
FBI's extensive resources the fact that
struck and several other FBI members of
the mid year team midair was the name of
the investigation into Hillary's emails
the fact that struck and several other
FBI members of the mid year team had
been assigned to the Russia
investigation which was extremely active
during the September and October time
period was not an excuse for failing to
take any actions during this time period
on the Weiner laptop in assessing the
decision to prioritize the Russia
investigation over following up on the
mid-year related investigative lead
discovered on the Weiner laptop we were
particularly concerned about the text
messages sent by strucken page that
potentially indicated or created the
appearance that investigative decisions
they made were impacted by bias or
improper considerations most of the text
message raising messages raising such
considerations pertained to the Russian
investigation and the implication in
some of those messages particularly
struck saga State thethe text message
will stop candidates from from being
elected was that struck might be willing
to take official action to impact the
presidential candidates electoral
prospects under these circumstances we
did not have confidence that Struck's
decision to prioritize the Russia
investigation over following up on the
media related investigative lead
discovered on the we not but weiner
laptop was free from bias in simpler
terms the IG there is saying Peter
struck might have been biased against
President Trump to the extent that he
was so focused on the Russia
investigation he decided to ignore
Hillary's emails and then by the time
they decided not to ignore Hillary's
emails was October 28th so the great
irony of that is that his focus on the
Trump investigation
Daisy hated Trump
and his non focused on Hillary because
he liked Hillary led him to leave
Hillary alone until right before the
election and then Comey ended up blowing
up Hillary's campaign that's the week of
the election so the irony is just
amazing these people are playing God and
they failed dramatically so I'll talk a
little bit more about this in just a
second so here's here's what that means
again here's what's so incredible about
about this what we just found out right
well we're finding out right now
according to the IG Peter struck was
texting that he would stop Trump from
being president Peter struck may very
well have made Donald Trump president
how because Peter struck was in charge
of the investigation into Hillary's
emails he was a high-ranking member of
that investigation he found out in late
September that he was going to that
there were more Hillary emails on the
computer on the Anthony Weiner computer
he did nothing about it for a full month
because he figured it was no big deal
but you know it was a big deal Russia
gate and so he was spending all of his
time investigating Russia gates and then
near the end of the election cycle
finally James Comey takes a look at this
and he goes oh well this is kind of bad
probably I should say something about it
now here's the part that's amazing so
0.8 you know we were going through the
12 points of this of this IG report that
are really vital to know point eight
Comey then revealed that the the
reopening of the investigation had to
happen he revealed that to Congress
because he thought that Hillary was
going to win and he wants to preserve
her legitimacy so again the irony here
is stunning Wright's truck holds off on
the Hillary investigation because he's
more focused on Trump because he wants
to get Trump and then Comey finds out
about it and because he thinks Hillary
is going to win he comes forward with
the letter so in other words if you
thought Hillary was gonna lose he
wouldn't have come forward with the
letter he wouldn't have gone out in
October 28th and said that Hillary's
investigation been reopened
if the election had been dead even at
that point which it was not right if
she'd not had a poll lead then he would
have held off on it but knowing that
Hillary had a poll lead figuring she
would win and wanting to legitimize
Hillary Clinton James Comey came forward
with the letter to Congress at that
point and that blew her up right she had
a poll lead at that point Polly
disappeared she ends up losing the
election here is what the report
explicitly says quote we found that
commis decision was the result of
several interrelated factors that were
connected to his concern that failing to
send the letter would harm the FBI and
his ability to lead it and his view the
candidate Clinton was going to win the
presidency and that should be perceived
to be an illegitimate president if the
public
learn of the information after the
election so in other words he thought
Hillary was gonna win and he want to
make her feel good he wanted to feel
legitimate and so he decided to release
the letter and then she lost which is
hilarious okay that's awesome and
hilarious
hey ninth point to know about the site
you report five separate agents who are
working on these cases sent pro-clinton
anti-trump techs many of which implied
using official authority to target
President Trump it turns out that not
only did five agents discuss their
support for Clinton they quote appeared
to mix political opinions with
discussions about the mid-year
investigation one agent texted quote no
one is going to prosecute Hillary
Clinton even if we find unique
classified material after the discovery
of Anthony Weiner's laptop
Lisa page texted about the possibility
of interviewing Clinton with fewer
agents in the room since quote she might
be our next president which struck
agreed page text instruct coat maybe
you're meant to stay where you are
because you're meant to protects the
country from that Menace meaning Trump
too which struck responded quote I'll
try and approach it that way I can
protect our country at many levels not
sure if that helps struck texted page
will stop it the it being Trump's
election struck texted page about an
insurance policy against the Trump
victory then excused it by saying that
he was just pushing for a quicker
investigation another FBI attorney who
we don't know yet texted viva la
resistance after the election after the
election struck texted regarding the
Special Counsel investigation he's asked
be part of the Moller investigation
quote for me and this case I personally
have a sense of unfinished business hey
none of this speaks of an FBI that is
interested in law enforcement it speaks
of a bunch of members of the FBI who
really are not now does that mean that
every decision the FBI made here was
politically corrupt no but it does mean
that we ought to look at every single
thing that struck had an impact on in
terms of decision making we should be
looking at every single thing these
other agents had an impact on in terms
of decision making now there are a
couple of ironic points that are that
are worth noting here too it turns out
that Comey struck and paged all use
personal email to conduct FBI business
yes illegal it's a violation of
procedure maybe the reason they decided
to let Hillary Clinton off the hook is
because they were all doing something
similar to what Hillary Clinton was
doing in an unrelated but damming point
this is amazing to according to the IG
report quote we identified numerous FBI
employees and all levels of the
organization and with no official reason
to be in contact for the media who are
nevertheless in frequent contact with
reporters
FBI agents received benefits from
reporters as well including golf outings
drinks and meals so when President Trump
said this place has a lot
you online there tons and tons of leaks
from the so-called deep state right from
people who work in the FBI and they were
basically being bribed by journalists
okay final point here the former
attorney assistant journalist an
attorney general Nick guy named Peter
Kazakh he should have recused himself
according to the IG well Hillary was
under investigation this former
assistant attorney general tried to get
his son a job on Hillary's campaign and
sent an email to John Podesta head of
the Clinton campaign which included the
schedule of the release of Clinton's
emails in in fYI a write Freedom of
Information Act litigation so that's a
lot to unpack in the IG report but the
takeaways are pretty simple there were
men of the FBI who hated Trump and
wanted to stop Trump and there were a
lot of decision the decisions that were
made they were made on a political basis
in an area where they should not have
been okay so in a second I want to talk
about all of the in a second I'm going
to talk about all of the reaction to all
of this first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over at Zeile so you know
it's a stressful period for us all right
it's a stressful time for us all but
that is why you need a massage and this
is what Zeile does better than anyone so
Zeile can bring a massage to your door
the entire thing right the massage table
but oils the scented candles the music
the whole thing they bring it right to
you and when they bring it right to you
your life becomes better because II
don't have to go to the spa and wait
around you have to pre schedule an
appointment and it is not that expensive
Zeile is just great I've gotten it for
my wife I've gotten it for my mom I've
gotten it from my dad I've got it for my
mother-in-law I've gotten it for my
sister like it's a great president it's
a really good Father's Day gift as well
by the way if you're looking for someone
get your dad for Father's Day the
massage at his house it's a pretty great
thing all you have to do is go to Zeile
calm or on zeals is iPhone or Android
app that's ze Elcom and you can select
from top local licensed pre-screened
massage therapists and you choose your
favorite technique gender preference
time and location for the massage Zeile
sends over one of their 10,000 licensed
massage therapists with all the
materials seven days a week 365 days a
year Zeile massage therapists can be at
your door and as little as an hour go
check it out right now to help you get
started our listeners get twenty five
bucks off their first massage with promo
code Benton that Cee Elcom promo code
benzio promo code Ben right now go to
Zeile come again and enter promo code
Ben you got 25 bucks off your first
in-home massage it's just awesome it's
one of those things that makes you feel
wealthy without actually having to break
the bank zeal comm promo code Ben go
check it out and get that special deal
bucks off alright so with all of that
said from the Inspector General report
the blowback has been enormous right
this year the blowback has been very
strong so president Trump this morning
he had a bunch of tweets on the IG
report he waited all day yesterday and
did not tweet about it and that's how
you knew that it was gonna be lit when
President Trump decided that he was
going to go on Twitter and go after it
so he really started he started tweeting
up a storm this morning he tweeted out
FBI agent Peter struck who headed the
Clinton and Russia investigations texted
to his lover Lisa page in the IG report
that will stop candidate Trump from
becoming president doesn't get any lower
than that true he says the IG report is
a total disaster for Comey his minions
and sadly the FBI Comey will now
officially go down as the worst leader
by far in the history of the FBI well
there's been some bad his leaders in the
history of the FBI but he will be one of
the more certainly I did a great service
to the people in firing him true good
instincts
yeah I love the president from pat's
himself on the back christopher ray will
proudly bring it back well we'll talk
about chris ray in just a second let's
talk about chris ray and in just in the
head of the FBI and whether he actually
is going to bring back the FBI but
president Trump then this morning
decided you know what Fox and Friends is
down on the lawn my friends over at Fox
and Friends
yeah great show I'm on it they they're
over on the lawn they're on the White
House lawn what if I just pop on down
there and just go and talk to my friends
so that's exactly what he did he popped
down there maybe he said a few things so
he he really went after a really went
out for the FBI which i think is is
pretty much appropriate I said on the
Department of Justice I would stay
uninvolved now I may get involved at
some point if it gets worse I say I'm
staying uninvolved I'm letting this
report go through I did nothing wrong
there was no collusion
there was no obstruction okay so if
President Trump says that he's gonna let
the report say what it says when he says
there was no collusion there was no
obstruction that's not in the report so
he actually said that the report
exonerated him of obstruction that
that's not actually true now it is true
that I don't think he obstructed I don't
think that there was collusion either
but that's not what this report says so
just to be perfectly exact an objective
about this 528 page report there's
nothing in there about the Russian
investigation per se but he is not wrong
when he rips into the FBI clearly now
what's hilarious is that the Democrats
are suggesting that all of this is all
of this was
actually the FBI attempting to help
President Trump Sarah Huckabee Sanders
yeah she came out yesterday and she said
that all of this reaffirms president
from suspicions about the FBI and she is
not wrong the president was briefed on
the IG report earlier today and it
reaffirmed the president's suspicions
about commis conduct and the political
bias among some of the members of the
FBI okay and that there is totally fair
then the Democrats get involved so Chuck
Schumer says really what the IG report
shows is that Hillary Clinton lost the
election because of political bias well
if you if you really believe that Comey
lost the election for her at the very
end she didn't lose it because come he
didn't like Hillary Clinton it turns out
that she lost it because Comey liked her
too much and that's the hysterical part
right Comey had a little dove in his
hand and that dove was the Hillary
Clinton campaign and he was trying to
guard it and keep it and pet it and be
friendly to it because he knew that one
day that dove would fly free and become
president and he wanted that dove to
have the strongest wings possible and so
well he was petting and he just sort of
he just sort of squished it and then the
campaign was sort of ripped the head off
the pigeon there James coming by
accident but the Democrats are taking
this report in the stupidest possible
way which is they're saying no what this
shows the FBI was biased against Hillary
Clinton yeah sure it was Trump who
benefited from all these mistakes so it
hardly reflects deep State or bias
against him at the end of the day the
actions reviewed in this report helped
Donald Trump win the election not the
other way around okay yes by accident by
accident that's the great hilarious
irony of all of this the FBI agents like
struck were so desperate to stop from
they actually made him president okay
that's the part that's really hilarious
in all of this and it really is really
it's really freaking funny it's it's
really funny now what is not so funny is
the fact that this is really bad for the
FBI and the DOJ right these are
institutions that we ought to trust as
Americans but we already knew that the
DOJ had become an Obama tool while Obama
was President of the United States and
the FBI I'm not particularly surprised
that all of this is coming out the
Hillary investigation was obviously a
battery from the very beginning and it
was botched all the way through and
political bias obviously you know in my
opinion played a part even though the
Inspector General found that it was it
was plausible how they treated the
investigation to say that no political
bias came into play it's like when
people say that there's no political
bias at university campuses because
people aren't overtly
as conservatives like well yeah but why
is it that every time something bad
happens it's to a conservative well in
this particular election cycle
everything that the FBI did that was
that was bad for someone on purpose was
directed at President Trump and
everything good that was directed at
someone on purpose was Hillary Clinton
except for that last letter which again
it turns out Comey was trying to do
something good for Hillary Clinton he's
just an idiot rather the stupidity of
our public officials cannot be
overstated it is extraordinary so cold
so Comey tweeted about it
Comey then tweeted that he was happy
with the IG report he said I respect the
DOJ IG office which is why I urge them
to do this review the conclusions are
reasonable even though I disagree with
some people of good faith can see an
unprecedented situation differently I
pray no director faces it again thanks
to the IG people for hard work okay well
yeah the they said your self
aggrandizing idiot who basically
destroyed the election cycle so yeah I
think that you should probably sit down
now and then hillary clinton got
involved
she then tweeted out this tweet out but
my emails okay because kyle cheney is a
reporter he tweeted out that the IG
found that Comey had used a personal
gmail account to conduct official u.s.
bi business and then she wrote but my
email so a couple of things about my
emails yes your emails you've made a
private server and then you stored all
this classified information on the
private server yes your emails the whole
point of the IG ripping into Comey is
that Comey did something wrong too but
Hillary Clinton is everybody else's
fault that Hillary Clinton lost the most
winnable election in American history
obviously the only person to blame is is
James Comey so that's pretty
extraordinary in just a second on gets
the FBI's response to all that first I
want to say thanks to our sponsors over
at expressvpn so with all this news
nowadays about how your personal
information is being exposed to online
every time you go to a public Wi-Fi
you're at risk of exposing your personal
information and you've got all of these
companies that are tracking all of your
information the Comcast and the
Verizon's and the Time Warner's well
this is why you ought to be taking back
your privacy with a VPN you ought to use
Express VPN my internet data is
encrypted my IP address is hidden that's
why I use Express VPN runs in the
background of my computer and it costs
less than seven bucks a month it is the
number one rated VPN service by
TechRadar and dozens of expert reviewers
expressvpn has these easy to use apps
takes five seconds to set it up I mean
it's really quick to set it up and then
you turn it on and just leave it on the
background your computer or your phone
and you don't have to worry about people
hacking your information again
or grant or grabbing your information
you want to make sure that hackers and
spies can't see your data expressvpn is
for you so go to expressvpn comm slash
man that's expr ESS VPN comm slash man
you got three months for free when you
get a one-year package which is pretty
awesome deal every day you use the
internet without expressvpn you're
putting yourself at risk don't be an
idiot
go get expressvpn today that's
expressvpn comm slash pin and you get
your first 3 months for free with a
one-year package again that's expressvpn
comm slash pen so go check that out ok
so I want to talk about the FBI's
response to all of this but first you're
gonna have to go over daily wire comm
and subscribe sum or $9.99 a month you
got the rest of the show for you get the
rest of this show live you also get to
be part of the mailbag which we are
doing today so you can ask me all your
questions and next week when we do the
conversation you get to be part of that
mailbag as well so you can ask questions
live and I will answer them next Tuesday
because we are doing an episode of the
conversation it's plus let me just be
frank your subscriptions help us bring
the show to you right if you don't
subscribe it's hard for us to bring the
show to you we got to make our money so
you got you got to subscribe it's just
the way that it works and week the
annual subscription you also get this
the very greatest and leftist ears hot
Oracle tumblers it is just phenomenal
you will love it it it was pretty great
yesterday I spoke in Dallas and there
are probably two dozen people who came
up with tub and with tumblers for
subscribers so become one of those
people because it is awesome check that
out for $99 a year also the Ben Shapiro
show is now available on Amazon alexa
and google homes so if you have a
virtual assistant you can listen to my
podcast with a simple voice command
after you enable the skill on alexa or
ask google to talk to the show for more
information just go check out our pin on
facebook and twitter plus subscribe at
youtube subscribe in iTunes because that
way you also are automatically going to
get our brand new Sunday special the
brand new Sunday special coming out this
one is with Michael Shermer the editor
of skeptic magazine he is an atheist I'm
religious person and we go at it over
religion and freewill and God and all
the big issues of life so check that out
as well we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so the FBI response to all of
this has been lackluster at best and
it's been particularly lackluster
because let's let's make one thing very
clear there's one huge question that has
yet to be answered by the DOJ or the FBI
that really crucial text that struck
cents a page the lens says we'll stop it
meaning we'll stop the Trump campaign
that was not handed over to Congress it
was only handed over to the inspector
general why didn't Congress have a right
to take a look at that why did we not
know about that you want to make
something look inspirit oriole cover it
up don't hand it over to the American
people don't hand it over to our elected
representatives handed over to the IG
instead that's really suspicious stuff
so anyway Christopher Rea is the new
head of the FBI he's Trump's head of the
FBI and he gives a presser in which he
talks about the future of the FBI
suffice it to say I am NOT sanguine
about the future of the FBI we accept
the findings of the report and the
recommendations we've drawn a number of
things on that regard
first we issued a new media policy
that's much stricter and much more clear
than what had been in place before
second we're going to be doing intensive
training on exactly those issues things
like the one that you alluded to that
includes contacts with the media Ford
we're gonna make painfully clear to
everybody that we won't tolerate
non-compliance and then last I've asked
our OPR to take a hard look at whether
or not they think the penalties that
exist right now are sufficient to deal
with that kind of contract
okay good so we're going to tighten the
penalties and education reeducation
people it's just like when Starbucks is
caught in the middle of a bias situation
they're now going to shut down the
baristas shut down the FBI we're gonna
re-educate people it shouldn't leak to
the media and be politically biased yeah
good luck with that good luck with that
we'll see how we'll see how that works
for you I am NOT particularly enthused
by the response that we have seen here
from Christopher Ray it's just not it's
just a big nothing burger full of
nothing and then my favorite part is
that chris ray came out and he said that
nothing in the report impugns the
integrity of the FBI or the work force
you mean aside from that part where it
said that half the FBI agents are being
bribed by journalists to talk to them or
are you talking about the part where
five different FBI agents were texting
to each other about how much they hate
Trump and wish that he would die basic
which part of that didn't impugn the FBI
exactly here's Chris Rea nothing nothing
in this report impugns the integrity of
our workforce as a whole or the FBI as
an institution oh oh is that it okay
well I guess then I guess that solves
everything I mean if I had only known
that Chris Rea was going to respond this
way I feel so much better about
everything now the Chris Rea has
intervened look what we have here is a
typical government agency I don't want
to suggest that there's a giant
conspiracy going on that there are a
bunch of agents in a room together
deciding how do we stop Trump or
anything like that what you have here is
a soft bias that manifests itself in
particular decision-making and this was
true with the IRS when when Obama was
president it is true with regard to
Hollywood for example it's why all of
Hollywood's material is left because you
have a bunch of people who agree on
stuff and it's an echo chamber and this
impacts decision-making political bias
does not actually have to manifest
itself in obvious political
decision-making sometimes it manifests
itself in bias in action that is eminent
and eminently obvious to anyone who's
observing so when you look at the media
and it turns out that every story they
get wrong is anti-trump you maybe
they're not getting the story's wrong on
purpose many many of these times but you
have to start saying well maybe the
reason they're getting these stories
wrong all the time about Trump but they
never got a story wrong about Hillary
Clinton or Barack Obama or at least not
nearly as often
maybe the reason is because they like
Hillary and they liked Obama and so even
unconsciously
they're more likely to believe things
that are bad about Trump than they are
likely to believe things that are bad
about Hillary Clinton or Barack Obama
right I think the same sort of attack I
think the same sort of logic plays into
what the FBI was doing here you have a
ton of FBI agents who hated Trump and
who are in top positions and saw a
stopping Trump as a priority does that
mean that there was an actual plan that
was snapped into place at the first
available opportunity we don't know
maybe there was I mean we'll find out
when the when the inspector general
report comes out on the Russia
investigation presumably but was there a
motive
sure and was there an opportunity sure
and was there a means turns out yes they
just botched the job okay if it wasn't
if it was a hit on Trump it was an
attempted hit because obviously it
didn't succeed it's a damning report
it's a damning report and the FBI is
gonna need a thorough cleaning from top
to bottom but I'm not sure how you clean
any major agency is the truth unless you
set up a bunch of checks and balances
eternal internally I'm not sure look
maybe you have somebody who's so
job it is to check all of the agents
text messages to make sure that they're
not using their their phones for this
sort of of communication whatever it is
that something has to be done to check
and balance this branch of government
because it's just out of control it's
really out of control okay time for the
mailbag and then I have a lot of things
I like in a lot of things that I hate
today so we have a lot left to do in the
show so mail bag it up MIT chris has
been I was having a conversation with
one of my good friends recently and he
said that he agrees with affirmative
action
he's a traditional liberal meets a
libertarian not left or leftist he
agrees with affirmative action though
he's Korean because he said data
suggests that without affirmative action
most colleges would be predominantly
white and then folks of color even with
comparable or better scores wouldn't get
in well it'd be a response to this
argument well that argument is
completely wrong okay the fact is that
without affirmative action it is
possible that a disproportionate number
of people would be white most likely a
disproportionate number of people would
be Asian but that is not because of
inherent discrimination in the system
it's because on the average black
students were applying to college have
lower scores than white students or
Asian students who are applying to
college I mean that's not racism that's
just a fact
and so when you just take the objective
measures the people with higher scores
tend to not be members of certain
minority groups now that doesn't explain
why that happens and something we have
to try and cure but the solution is not
to say that people who aren't
unqualified for a particular college to
go to that college over other people
this is particularly true with regard to
Asians so this is the amazing thing your
friend you say your friend it's Korean
Chris well let me point out there's a
report today in the New York Times
Harvard rated Asian American applicants
lower on personality traits lawsuit says
quote Harvard consistently rated Asian
American applicants lower than any other
race on personal traits like positive
personality likability courage kindness
and being widely respected according to
an analysis of more than 160,000 student
records filed Friday in federal court in
Boston by a group representing Asian
American students in a lawsuit against
the university's American
asian-americans scored higher than
applicants of any other racial or ethnic
group on admissions measures like test
scores grades and extracurricular
activities according to analysis
commissioned by a group that opposes all
race-based admissions criteria well the
students personal ratings significantly
drag down their chances of being
admitted the analysis found this is
institutional discrimination this is
institutional racism because what
happened here's a bunch of admissions
officers said too many Asians are
getting in so instead we'll just say
they're not personable or
they're not enough leadership qualities
they're not likable so basically we'll
in order to achieve our perfect ethnic
blend and in order to achieve the light
roast ethnic blend in order to do that
all we have to do really is put the
right ingredients in and we can't have
too many of these Asians right these
Asians you know if we have too many
Asians then the campus becomes to Asia
and the best way to stop that as well
just say that Asians are Schmucks I mean
that's really what this lawsuit says it
turns out that the suspicions of Asian
American alumni students and applicants
were right all along since the group
students for fair admissions Harvard
today engages in the same kind of
discrimination and stereotyping it used
to justify quotas on Jewish applicants
in the 1920s and 1930s
Harvard's own researchers cited a bias
against Asian American applicants in a
series of internal reports in 2013 but
Harvard ignored the findings the court
papers said and never publicly released
them okay so you probably ought to tell
your friend that it's not white people
who are the beneficiaries of lack of
affirmative action it's it's Asian
people and beyond that again colleges
are discriminating in favor of
particular races and against other races
in affirmative action they're not doing
so in the absence of affirmative action
brian says hey bud
back during the Obama administration we
talked about the President Obama not
giving legitimacy to Isis by calling
them JV and refusing to call the radical
Islamic terrorists there's always Isis
gain power destabilize the region and
killed a lot more people how was
president Trump supposed to solve the
problem in North Korea without
legitimizing and buttering up Kim Jong
loon after all the worst thing to do
during a negotiation is humiliate the
other party
Thanks well I don't think that he has to
humiliate the other party during the
negotiation this is why I don't think
the president should be directly
involved in the negotiation so I'll give
you an example today the President of
the United States was asked about the
situation in North Korea and he said a
couple of things that are not really
great right so he said this is clip 17
he's the head of a country and I mean he
is the strong head don't let anyone
think anything different he speaks and
his people sit up at attention I want my
people to do the same okay so he wants
he wants his own staffers to act like
him journalists and is that necessary to
prevent war
so President Trump says yes my president
Trump's case is that you have to flatter
him into not nuking us right he actually
said this right so here is here's clip
19 in the same breath you're defending
now Kim Jong Un's human rights records
how
you know why because I don't want to see
a nuclear weapon destroy you and your
family okay that's that's ridiculous I'm
sorry that's ridiculous
a kim jeong-hoon is not going to nuke
the United States because Donald Trump
doesn't call him a good guy okay for 30
years we calling him bad guy we have not
gotten a nuke up the tailpipe be from
from Kim jong-un you know why because
the real reason Kim jong-un is not
attacking us is because we will wipe him
out he will be vaporized within 10
seconds of firing a missile at the
United States I mean it's not just that
we have military superiority over the
North Koreans okay we could wipe them
literally in three hours that war would
be over three hours okay not three days
not three weeks because three weeks take
out Saddam Hussein which he gets three
hours to finish off the North Korean
regime if they decided to go to war with
us okay that's why they're not gonna
nuke us not because President Trump
decides to be nice now the reason I say
this is because Ronald Reagan did not
stop talking about how the Soviet Union
was a human rights violator in the
middle of negotiations of the Soviet
Union he was saying you guys are human
rights violators you're a terrible
country we're gonna try to come to a
deal with you anyway for in the interest
of mutual security but you do embolden
bad guys when you say to them that they
aren't wonderful and nice I've never
seen a situation ever in a negotiation
where you flatter someone into doing
something into doing what you want not
in the international sphere anyway maybe
it works in personal relationships it
doesn't Kim Jong Un's not going to
disarm because Trump is nice to him okay
it's not gonna happen
countries have interests those interests
do not change just because President
Trump is is being very nice to Kim Jong
hoon right now the worst thing to do
during a negotiation is not to humiliate
the other party the worst thing to do
during a negotiation is to flatter the
other party and to flatter yourself into
believing that the other party is
credible when it is not the worst
negotiation of all time was Munich the
worst negotiator
it's you'd have to name me a negotiation
that failed because one party was
humiliated
and that's really not how negotiations
fail typically now Austin says Ben I'm a
huge fan of the show I live in the
democratic state of California within
the warm Republican Orange County bubble
I know you live in LA I wanted to know
your thoughts on the possible positive
and negative effects of the California
three-way split on the November ballot
so first of all it's not going to happen
because in order for California to
become three states that has to be
approved by constant it has to be
approved by I believe 2/3 of the states
that's never going to happen it would
add another four Democratic senators
because just the way the demographics
break down the Northern California would
be Democrat central California be
Democrat
and kind of the in Southern California
be Democrat so III think that it is it's
foolish politically but the answer to to
the failures of California state
government is that it should be smaller
and we should devolve more authority
back to localities Colt says out of all
the founding fathers is there one you
look up to the most or have a deeper
respect for than the others if so we'd
love to hear your thoughts I am a big
Adams fan I love John Adams writing
their bait between John Adams and Thomas
Jefferson over the nature of government
and the extensive government is is some
of the most intelligent writing ever
done go buy a copy of Adams and
Jefferson's letters to one another if
you want to read some of the most
brilliant writing ever done and he's
amazing you have two greatest you know
greatest minds of the millennia probably
you know sitting there talking to one
another and you actually got a window
into their mind it's pretty amazing I'm
also pretty fond of James Madison as
well for obvious reasons Wesley says hi
Ben I was wondering what you thought
about space travel and if you think NASA
should be involved in a future trip to
Mars
should this be the goal for the federal
government or should it be left entirely
to private companies like SpaceX well
I'm not averse to private companies
taking the lead on all of this it
depends on whether you think that future
Mars is a security consideration whether
it actually benefits the United States
to get to Mars first I would say
probably yes I'd I think that it
benefitted the United States to have
sovereignty over the moon basically I
think that that there are other
countries that are going to attempt to
do that and leaving it up to private
industry to exploit the resources of
Mars then it seems like we'd be better
off having a sort of collective control
at least in terms of American government
at the outset over over Mars because
otherwise it could turn into a corporate
competition but I I see arguments the
other way as well I'm kind of torn on it
honestly on the spur the moment basis
Zachary says regretfully I missed the
Father's Day podcast when I realized I
missed and I frantically tried to log on
to ask the following question I'm 23
years old well a few weeks ago my father
has a history of drunkenness got drunk
and fought my eighteen year old brother
situation ended up with him holding a
gun to my mom and him spending the
weekend in jail in the fastway pot we
have fought and this isn't the first
time there's been domestic issues
although it is the first time that has
involved a gun after speaking with him
after he got out of jail he seemingly
tries to deflect and shift the blame
onto my mom and little brother I could
try to forgive him if he'd hold himself
accountable for his actions but it
doesn't seem like he is going to as a
result he and I haven't spoken for close
to a month usually we talked two to
three times a week what do I do I find
that I feel incapable of forgiving him a
must expects responsibility should I
forgive him because it is the right
thing to do well no no
I mean you don't forgive people unless
they want to be forgiven it is not your
job to forgive someone like in your own
heart you can understand his flaws right
so that you can live with yourself but
you do not have to go out of the way to
pretend that he's asked for forgiveness
when he has not or to grant him
repentance when he is not ready the
Jewish version of repentance requires
actual repentance right you are supposed
to repent I'll speak from the Jews point
of view because I'm more familiar with
it from the Christian point of view
Christianity obviously has a whole
different philosophy with regard to
repentance and Jesus repenting for your
sins whether you want it to or not but
Judaism suggests that you must do
individual individual repentance several
times a day right we actually have a
paragraph in what we call the shamone s
reign which you repent at least three
times a day which is a lot of repenting
right but human beings do a lot of
sitting in order for you to be forgiven
you have to repent and order for your
dad for you in order for you to forgive
your dad in in the sense that you're
going to grant him added credibility
again he's gonna need to do some real
teshuva is the word in Hebrew Bobby says
hey Ben I'm having my first child in
August he's gonna be a boy well
congratulations that is awesome sauce my
wife and I've heard from many parents we
should buy the child a tablet to watch
shows and play games on the go my
question is what's a good way to expose
the child's technology without it being
a babysitter or a replacement for social
interaction I'm afraid to let my child
even have interaction with them while
they're young but on the opposite side
of that I don't want him to be behind on
the tech side thanks Bobby first of all
um and he says he thinks he's gonna name
him Benjamin well thank you I mean I
assume that's after me and not after
Franklin but I'll take it anyway in any
case but children under the age of two
this is what social science suggests
should not be using electronics of any
sort they can use you know the toys that
you hit and then electronically respond
they shouldn't have tablet time or
screen time our psalms did not watch TV
until he was two TV acts like a drug I
mean you can you can see with kids when
you read to them they're active and
they're involved when they watch TV very
often they just zone out and it acts
like a parent yeah and even with older
kids you have to have that in mind so
our daughter we restrict the amount of
TV that you can watch very regularly
that doesn't mean that we're responsible
all the time right there are times and
we have to do something and it's like
okay we don't have time for you right
now
sit in front of the TV right just like
every other parent we have our we have
our own moments but that doesn't mean
that you should make it a regular part
of of they're watching lives that's it I
think the TV can be wonderful I think
that the technology can be wonderful
kids are adapted figuring this stuff
out if you don't teach her four-year-old
how to use a tablet when the kids have
until you learn how to use a tablet
that's just the way that it works my
two-year-old son is already learning
kind of manipulate my phone now David
says dear bettin from your perspective
how well do you think human intellect
can understand God the ancient Greeks
seem to believe human intellect was the
key to understanding God if God is
beyond understanding intellectual tools
what other tools can be used to
understand God and gods well so I'm
writing an entire book about this right
now even in my view of this is that the
is that it is our job to use reason to
try and understand the universe that God
built in order to understand God's logic
right I believe in the sort of Greek
teleology that the universe was designed
with certain purposes in mind and then
it's our job to try and find those
purposes that said God operates from a
different plane so trying to understand
the mind of God completely is never
going to happen I think that the most
beautiful exposition of this happens in
the book of Exodus when when Moses asked
to see God's face and what the
commentators explains that when Moses
asked to see God's face what he's really
asking is can I understand the universe
and God says you can't look at my face
if you look at my face then you will die
but I will let you see my back right and
he puts Moses in a cleft in the rock and
then he goes by Moses right all of this
is anthropomorphic just because human
beings can't understand completely
spiritual imagery and the and my dad has
a very nice kind of what we called VAR
torah on this he has a very nice sort of
exposition on what this means what he
says is that people that you know and
people that you love and that you know
you can recognize them from behind right
if I saw my wife I could recognize her
from behind if I saw my kids I could
recognize them from behind but I can't
tell what's on their faces I don't know
what they're thinking
because I can't see what's on their face
but I certainly can tell that they are
there and that's I think what the
intellect can comprehend in selecting
comprehend that God is there we can see
sort of shadows of what God wants from
us through revelation I think we can see
more than shadows but just through pure
intellect through pure reason I think
that we can gather a couple of things I
think we can gather you know the idea
that there is a God I think there are
good arguments for a god the idea that
there is a God who is the creator of
heaven and earth I think that we can
pick up on on certain interactions
between man and man they don't that that
don't even require belief in God
necessarily to logic yourself out to
some but as far as understanding what
God wants from us I think that that
that's only going to take you so far I
think that you can you can get to the
Aristotelian logic of God wants us to
use real
dad wants us to act in accordance with
rhe right reason which amounts to virtue
but that is relatively vague and
Aristotle did as well as anybody even
Aristotle's philosophy has some flaws
and in how he brings out virtue okay
Jacob says hi bet you've been very
instrumental to me in rediscovering my
belief in God I love your approach to
faith and how it's fundamental to
creating a system of morality
however friend of mine holds this out of
the belief that we can create a system
of morality based on the one truth that
suffering exists and therefore we should
try to reduce it wherever possible do
you believe that this concept point of
any belief in God can create a stable
Society I love everything you do well
this was an Enlightenment project right
so since Thomas Hobbes there's been a
project going on saying that human
beings are that that our rights derived
not from God they don't arrive from
nature but what our rights really are
based on is this idea that we are trying
to avoid pain and suffering and to
maximize pleasure and we can build an
entire system of morality around this
fundamental basis I don't think that
that's correct the reason I don't think
that's correct is because we all define
suffering differently right there there
are many decisions we make in life where
we choose to suffer with the knowledge
that there'll be something on the other
end or we choose to suffer because
something means more to us in terms of a
group identity then our personal non
suffering means to us how for example if
you're trying to say that you're
minimizing suffering for example how do
you build a system in which soldiers
sacrifice themselves for the greater
good but it's very difficult to explain
that right altruism is difficult to
explain along the lines of personal
minimization of suffering and personal
maximization of pleasure and this has
been an ongoing struggle forever right
you have contines Golden Rule on the one
hand and then you also have jeremy
bentham's logic of utilitarianism on the
other and both of these claim that they
are designed to minimize human suffering
and maximize human pleasure basically
but those are the very different realms
of thought Marxism thought that it was
designed to maximize human pleasure and
minimize human suffering and that ends
it in the death of a hundred million
people so I don't believe that pure
human reason can get you there I don't
think that without a God without a
certain teleology to the universe
without trying to find out what it is
that nature wants of you and and what it
is that the universe is is demanding of
you and what is the God is demanding of
you from a judeo-christian ethic I don't
think you can get to a full morality and
the founders believed the same even-even
Conte is based on the basic ideas of
judeo-christian morality he sort of just
backdoors them into his own logic okay
so a couple of things I like and then
we'll do a thing that I hate and then
we'll be out of here so things that I
like today
so there's a show this show is not for
the kiddies I'm not even sure it's for
the adults honestly it's a pretty dirty
show Animal Kingdom on TNT if they could
cut out all the sex scenes it would be a
lot shorter it would also be better in
my opinion because I mean frankly I
don't find sex scenes all that
interesting because it's pretty much the
same every time but in any case the show
itself is if you like Breaking Bad if
you are into sort of crime families
Animal Kingdom is about this mother and
her four sons and her grandson who are
basically a crime syndicate and it is
it's compelling it's certainly
compelling to watch it is very purple
right it's over the top but it's but
it's well acted and it's well scripted
here here's what it looks like
here in this family you're gonna be
seeing things things that need to stay
in this family
we do all the work she controls the cash
my boys know their limits
okay so the show itself is is very
compelling stuff it's again it's it's
it's almost like a short form soap opera
and but it is it is not something that
instills a a grand sense of morality
right I mean these people are all scum
so it's a show about scummy people so
that's our kind of thing then then
you'll enjoy the show okay other thing
that I like is an actual thing that I
like so steve scalise who you'll
remember a year ago was shot I know how
we all forgot about like a bunch of
Congress people getting shot but that
was pretty horrifying right I mean that
was kind of bad and we sort of forgot
about all that anyway Steve Scalise the
first pitch of the Congressional
baseball game he's back now and you can
watch him make a play
[Applause]
so that's pretty fun hey then thank God
Steve Scalise is healthy again and
that's a pretty amazing thing so these
we should just be grateful for that
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate so the thing I hate number one
Brooke Baldwin I did a whole routine on
CNN yesterday about female athletes
making less money than men and here's
what it sounded like
whatdo Serena Williams Danica Patrick
Lindsey Vonn Ronda Rousey and Maria
Sharapova all have in common they're all
badass women not on the list of the 100
highest-paid athletes in the world in
fact not a single woman is on that list
not one we need to start speaking up
about this we need to stand up for what
we're worth
okay that's stupid and I would tell you
why that is stupid the reason that is
stupid is because the reason they are
not on the top hundred list is because
none of the sports in which they play
have as high income as the comparative
sports for men I'm not a single woman is
on that list because as it turns out
Danica Patrick who made ten point three
million dollars as opposed to Lewis
Hamilton's 51 million or Serena Williams
is 18 million to Roger Federer or 77
million okay
the reality is that all of these leagues
earn less for women okay so the Austral
yeah who sports reports the male
viewership at the Australian Open
eclipsed female viewership by twenty
five percent and in general the men's
ATP World Tour events generate
significantly larger audiences according
to statistics compiled by BBC this is
according to a man's a Presta giacomo
over at Daily wire according to
according to Yahoo Sports statistics
compiled by the BBC the ATP that's the
men's tour through nine hundred seventy
three million viewers in 2015 compared
to the WTA's 395 million viewers well it
turns out if you're on a lower rated
show you get paid less they found a
lower rated tour you get paid less and
this is true in soccer right nobody
watches women's soccer in in non Olympic
years and even during Olympic years
men's soccer gets much higher ratings
and also the women negotiate their own
deals so the point here is not that
women shouldn't be paid lots of money
for sports the point is that if you are
just looking at Danica Patrick versus
Lewis Hamilton or whatever I don't
follow NASCAR if you're just looking at
the leading men's drivers of leading
women's driver well that's because the
leading men's driver is in NASCAR like
she won less money because she's in the
same sport and she didn't win as men
races like not sure what the big problem
was there and Serena Williams not
earning as much money because fewer
people watch women's tennis then watch
men's tennis which is fine people should
be able to watch what they want but then
this is all very silly again this comes
down to the leftist belief that all
disparity equals discrimination and that
is of course ridiculous okay meanwhile
one more thing that I hate so the
Democrats continue to trot forth this
narrative that Donald Trump is forcibly
separating families at the border the
reason again the tunnel Trump is
separating families at the border is
because when you arrest people at the
border there is a law on the books that
has been ensconced by the 9th Circuit
Court of Appeals that says that children
are not allowed to stay in detention
even if their parents are there they're
not allowed to stay in detention for
longer than 20 days and so if you wish
to arrest the parents then the children
have to be placed somewhere else
it is not the Donald Trump just wants
these kids to go away now there are
people in his administration who said
dumb things like John Kelly said this
should be a way of discouraging illegal
immigration is to separate kids from
their parents well that's kind of gross
I mean there plenty of ways to
discouraging illegal immigration it
seems to me punishing children is not
the best way to do that but the law
itself is pretty clear on this you're
not allowed to keep children in custody
with their parents so if you want to
keep the parents in custody you have to
separate out the kids well the Democrats
of course have to have suggested that
Trump is forcibly doing this because he
hates children or somesuch and the media
just parroting the Democrats does the
same thing here is Nancy Pelosi saying
that there should be uprisings over
family separations they're doing away
with children being with their moms this
is I I just don't even know why there
aren't uprisings all over the country
and maybe there will be when people
realize that this is a policy that they
defend it's a horrible thing okay so
then the media immediately picks up on
all of this and because the media are
basically a tool of the Democratic Party
they decide that they are going to
repeat the same question over and over
in order so here's Bryan Karam a CNN
reporter going after Sarah Huckabee
Sanders basically using Nancy Pelosi's
language you're a parent don't you have
any empathy for what these people are
going through
they have less Drive trying to be
serious but I'm not gonna have you yell
a lot of firm Chili's it's a law and
they have that these people have nothing
hey I know you want to get some more TV
it is absolutely about TV time it is it
absolutely about TV time which is why
he's ranting and raving on TV
right the White House there's a good
case we made that the White House press
corps should submit questions in writing
or that at the very least that they
should not televised these things live
because you just have too many CNN
reporters and too many reporters of all
stripes who are looking for their who
are looking for their payday basically
by rip it doing the sam donaldson
routine while i grilled the press
secretary today I'm not sure how much
information that even comes from these
press conferences in the first place
they just seem like a sideshow to me
frankly because it is the job of the
press secretary to lie as often as
possible to the media and the job of the
media to get on TV as often as possible
and none of it seems to actually be
conducive to the truth in any serious
way which is why you end up with
situations like this I have to admit I
left Jim Acosta who's just awful at
Siena and their White House reporter he
also goes after Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and and she's finally had enough I can
say that it is very biblical to enforce
the law that is actually repeated a
number of times throughout the Bible
however this hold on Jim if you'll let
me finish again I'm not going to comment
on the attorneys specific comments that
I haven't seen I know it's hard for you
to understand even short sentences I
guess but in please don't take my words
out of context but the separation of
illegal pham alien families is the
product of the same legal loopholes that
Democrats refuse to close and these laws
are the same that have been on the books
for over a decade
and the president is simply enforcing
them okay so Jim Acosta deserves that
one okay just good for Sarah Huckabee
Sanders Jim Acosta man the grandstanding
from the podium from people like Acosta
is really egregious okay
so we'll be back here next week we have
we have a lot to talk about then also
make sure that you tune in to our Sunday
show as well because we have Michael
Shermer on it's a really great
conversation I think you're really going
to enjoy it if you like all the talk
about God and free will and and reason
then please check it out we are the we
we love having you we love having you
subscribe so please do that as well and
we will see you here on on Sunday and
then we'll see her on Monday I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the venture Pierrot show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018